quite a year ago I was invited to a
wedding in Japan a woman named kayo
who's Japanese was marrying a Japanese
American and she and her husband she
said her big fans of yours truly and
they invited me to their wedding which
was really nice and they sent me all
these treats and I couldn't go of course
but I'm here I'm now in Tokyo and I
found out where they're living which is
right down here so let's go say hi
anybody there
[Applause]
[Music]
are you yeah fabulous yeah how was the
way he was yes sorry I missed it sorry I
wanted to be there yeah but I realized
it's six thousand miles and I don't know
you
Oh beautiful beautiful I wish I had been
able to go cool if I crash here okay
this is just a man you invited to your
wedding showing up a year later and
lying in bed with you and your husband I
know that you guys are fans of the show
what are there things that you like most
about the show you like jordan shlonsky
and sometimes he irritates me doesn't he
do you see it when he irritate you you
don't think he would irritate you okay
well that's that's good because we have
a gift for you
I look around your house and I see a lot
of clues that this is representative of
Japanese culture I see minimalism I see
that every object has a place I see that
every object belongs some of them
there's almost a spiritual energy here
and in fact I can see that everything is
placed very carefully like that never
appears that something just fell into
place for example you have smart choices
and minimalist choices when I see few
things I look at each thing and it makes
me go deeper into each of those things
so I'll like I'll look at your Lego toys
right there and I look very deep and I
can see all the details and the minutiae
now these are details that you toiled
over we do four to two weeks a year so
now you're talking about 42 weeks of
shows a year now how can I maintain my
sense of self in a world that wants to
defeat me it requires incredible
strength for the forest
you